はい10月今日はですねビジネスにもチョコエッグっぽいなかったんですよ
これが果たして本当にちょいってか開けてみないとわかんないんでえっ理由マーサー
不安だなぁ1本へホランドジュースより安いんですよ
ちょっと嫌な予感があった
ですけど車庫えっクリスかなと
中身が伴わないですよねっ
ん
me
の
ウズ
うん
なんだ道
どう開ければいいかも
わからないんですけども普通にあ
まあ開け方もなんか日本と違いますからね
ん
f
なんだからあ
monsters モンスターやツアー
はい完成目玉よちょっとは多いのしか見たことないんでわかんないし
これだけは理解してほしいんですけどそうメッセーの言えねぇなんか一人グラスの時
みたいに
ねーっとカー wii とか発狂したなう
絶対引かれると思うし日本人なんか日本人みんなそんな人と顔を思われたら嫌なんで
部屋で取る時はちょっとんどな責めにさせてください本当に日本のためにもよろしくお
願いします
ずっとホールステッチやいい子でいたいからさ
頼みは本当にっ
右側は理解してほしいと
ていた
こんな子なんだ
とっ
あの頃これはもう外れですねモンスターズインク皿に地点でもほらなんかよくあるなん
かほらなんか
遊んで遊ぼうみたいなんですね
ん
surf いうことでイギリスにはチョコいくがあるんで
チョコエッグ
voodoo